if you miss a line in the game you reset
you miss it on the track
you could die
who do you think the best driver is
probably Rory I would dust him in a lap
yeah all you do is play video games with
some crazy dreams of racing cars Doug
you're the one that told us to always do
something we love you know what racing
cars cost
look around it's not our world son
what is this it's a contest
the best Gran Turismo players in the
world
get a chance to compete in professional
racing dude this is real
[Applause]
I'm sorry you really think you're gonna
take a kid who plays video games in
their bedroom you're gonna strap them to
a 200 mile an hour rocket it'll tear
them to pieces
it's not gonna work the guys who race
are Elite athletes
your kids are scrawny little gamer kids
well that's why you coming come on let's
go
must be a new experience for you moving
your legs
you puked on my lawn there's no turning
back now when you're in a race the
cockpit is going to be 140 degrees
Fahrenheit
the g-forces will be twice when an
astronaut experiences upon liftoff I
can't see anything
hey you get extra points for that in the
game
[Music]
I'll never give up this whole thing is
insane but out of the Couchsurfing nerds
that you sent me he is the best one he
made it
welcome to Team Nissan
of the game is called racing
if you miss the line in the game you
reset you miss it on the track
you could die
I know this track
man a gray set a thousand times
that's what I'm talking about